I would never give a light to a tree by
the way I would absolutely okay
cigarette with a tree unless it did that
huge giveaway uh uh trees a german nazi
soldier oh my god
so i know you're a huge supporter of the
military yeah i think i think and you
know back in the day we had to give our
boys information during the war world
war two right one of the ways that that
was done was through cartoons to give
them a message you would give them a
message to like train them and to show
them different ways to do things the
soldiers
oh you mean you would show like instruct
like informative cartoons of cartoons
okay
Looney Tunes was involved just wait and
these are actually to inform the actual
soldiers and they were like you know
what's gonna make it super informative
talking duck yeah everyone who did these
heady an FBI clearance everyone who did
what these cartoons everyone who worked
on these cartoons had to get FBI
clearance because they're getting
top-secret information to make their
cartoon oh you'll see
so these are terrible cartoons so they
are now now a lot of stuff sighs roll em
David okay private snafu what is
happening this is our guy
Wyatt election you ever get a lecture on
cares like a master class you don't know
that and you're going into combat this
is the first guy who did oh yeah
put a leaf of his Highness dog
watch.watch oh oh I never I don't think
that's camouflage they're saying that's
not good that's a Nazi right okay by the
way if you get shot by Nazi guns just
turn into a jeep faint covers stupid
yeah okay who is entering the Armed
Forces and also dr. Seuss is involved in
these wait what Dave what the army this
is not helpful to it you're like oh so
we got bicycles and brooms okay good to
know
it's dusters oh we got hey unicycles you
know like tow she says I let his doctor
she was really involved in this yeah
is he really yeah what is going on uh
isn't all and you're smoking
don't let the tree grab it otherwise
it'll finish you last brick how nice
uh uh Trey's a German Nazi soldier oh my
god I would never steal it I would never
give a light to a tree by the way I
would absolutely smoke a cigarette with
a tree unless it did that huge giveaway
it is just yeah
wait a minute enemy sometimes uses
camouflage - this would not be helpful
this is very helpful if you're now you
know not to sit in trees it could be
dude if the tree smokes and blows us was
the guy it's a Nazi tree
hey it feels better Mary goes oh right
of course that's the worst one okay so
you're soldiers you're going to combat
or you're in combat and they're like hey
there's something we need to show you
about combat and you watch this and
you're like ah it's really what was I
supposed to learn this is what war was
like well it seems kind of fun there you
go all good shadow yep
[Music]
yeah private snafu we've got his back
yeah this this save lives did it
probably not okay
huh so this is just purely for
entertainment no this is what you're
supposed to do in war they did not think
that this would help any soldier and get
the shadow you get in the shadow how
many of our boys were saved by being in
shadows man if I hadn't watched that
cartoon before this Hitler would have
got me well there's a show now I can't
see but it's gone okay what's our lesson
the lesson is if you want to fool them
remember this [ __ ] believe what what
[Music]
what Jesse what he means no I don't see
what yeah I do not see what he means you
see the rock on those ladies what just
happened at the end okay well no wonder
not see stopped oh my god feel good I I
just can't imagine the army being like
boy mail you knocked it out of the park
did that's perfect you did you know if
you stay in the shadow the only thing
that could get you is a Nazi hot air
balloon private snafu don't get in that
Nazi hot air balloon shadow yeah no for
sure and then yeah and then keep your
eyes open for German
puffing trees we learned a lot of things
yeah except at the end and every moment
before that
[Music]
you